[Music]
the fifth episode of the mandalorian
second season revealed that baby yoda is
really baby grogu
and introduced in live action one of
star wars most fearsome
jedi warriors the episode also featured
some fun easter eggs for fans to find
here are a few you may have missed
shortly after the impressive live-action
debut of ahsoka tano
chapter 13 jumps to mando and grogu
arriving on corvus to meet with the
tegruta force user about potentially
teaching the little one
they promptly land and make their way to
a nearby settlement where they are
welcomed by barren grungy streets
with sparse inhabitants among them is an
ad series smelter droid first
introduced in the original star wars
trilogy the most notable of this run of
droid went by the moniker 88
and appeared on the big screen for the
first and only time in return of the
jedi it didn't hold the spotlight for
very long that's its biggest claim to
fame as being the one responsible for
torturing a gunk droid
at jabba's palace over the years however
this brand of droid has become a
frequent background presence
across other forms of star wars media
including the animated series the clone
wars and the galaxy's edge novels
mando is barely in town five minutes
before the magistrate summons him to
speak with her
she gets right to the point offering
mando a spear made out of pure besgar if
he kills ahsoka
while he doesn't necessarily accept the
job formally he does secure from his
wannabe employer a set of coordinates
to find the jedi he and his foundling
set off into the mangled wilderness
but little do they know something is
watching them high above their heads
resting on a tree branch
sits an owl-like creature known as a
convoy rebels and clone wars fans
surely recognize the significance of
these birds as they're prevalent
throughout ahsoka's journey in the star
wars canon
and represent the purity of the light
side of the force dave filoni who wrote
and directed chapter 13
has gone on record saying that these
creatures are also observers
and protectors and the one present in
the mandalorian just before ahsoka
arrives to defend herself against mando
fits that description perfectly
ahsoka mando eventually comes to an
agreement that benefits them both
if he helps her displace the magistrate
and free her settlement
she'll take grogu under her wing and
hone his forced powers
according to mando the magistrate is
always flanked by two hk87 assassin
droids
which fans of the star wars the old
republic mmo were surely recognized as
bad news
hunter killer droids first arrived via
the 2003 star wars knights of the old
republic video game
and were characterized as highly
efficient assassins known and feared for
their stealth
various models took center stage
depending on the story
the most notable being darth revan's
personally constructed hk47 others
appeared all over old republic era media
until it was stricken from the universe
back in 2012 following disney's purchase
of the star wars ip their unsuccessful
attempt to stop mando and ahsoka
also marks their first live-action
appearance in the franchise
once the jedi and the mandalorian make
it back to the village they get started
right away and infiltrate at stick walls
and in true star wars fashion a massive
firefight ensues from there
severely outnumbered ahsoka has no
choice but to utilize a stealth approach
to take down her enemies
at one point in the fight she begins
traversing the back alleys in an effort
to box her opponents in
leading them to carefully sweep the area
and apparently frustrating the local
tuca population
this lovable yet dangerous feline has
become a staple of star wars media over
the past few years
dating back to their earliest
appearances on the clone wars the most
well-known sub-species of tuca is a lot
cat
a frequent face in rebels and a handful
of doctor apha comics
as well as in other various books and
shows
well we've been out here for hours and
all i've seen are these stinking loath
cats
additionally this isn't their debut in
the mandalorian either as one variety of
tuka popped up in the season one episode
is sanctuary scaring grogu
unsurprisingly the magistrate can't hold
her own for very long against ahsoka
tano
and ultimately loses their duel the jedi
knocks the spear from her opponent's
hands holding a lightsaber up to her
neck as a form of intimidation
hoping to get the information out of her
that she desires she demands her foe to
reveal the location of grand admiral
thrawn
non-rebels viewers might be a bit lost
here but for those who spend plenty of
time with the ghost crew right up until
the series finale this is exactly the
question they've waited years to find
out the answer to a holdover from the
non-canon star wars expanded universe
grand admiral thrawn burst on the rebel
scene at the beginning of season 3.
during the liberation of lothal at the
end of season four
thrawn and ezra bridger were shot into
hyperspace by a group of purgil
and haven't appeared in any star wars
media since ahsoka and sabine wren
set out to find them shortly after but
as evidenced by the mandalorians reveal
the search goes on at the end of chapter
13
ahsoka doesn't necessarily hold up her
end of the deal once again refusing to
train grogu
but she does give mando a push in the
right direction just before he and his
foundling
board the razer crest for their next
adventure she advises that they set out
for the planet typhon
where the ruins of an ancient jedi
temple reside there grogu can sit on a
seeing stone
and decide between letting his force
abilities go or continuing his long
dormant training you might even be able
to connect with one of the few jedi
left roaming the stars typhon is fairly
new to the star wars universe but it's
important to the overall history of the
galaxy is immense
located in the deep core and shrouded in
mystery typhon is one of the planets
considered the birthplace of the jedi
religion
it has yet to appear on the big or small
screen but served as a central plot
point in the 40th issue
of the dr afrika comics and got a
passing mention in the high republic
number one comic
it's entirely likely that fans will have
the chance to learn more about this
legendary locale and its backstory
as the mandalorian's killer second
season marches on
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mandalorian are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one